you guys ready to have a good time away
you can do better than that you got rid
of the towel
welcome to all things comedy live
podcast with Bilbo and al Madrigal
please give a warm welcome to your host
okay thank you for coming out to the
belly room
belly room we're sitting real low aren't
we
way back in the last row it's at five
rows away this always gives you a thrill
to try to sell this place out you know
another sold-out performance for all
things comedy
I'm glad we're in chairs you guys don't
usually they'd put a stool up here and I
wouldn't be able to walk straight for
[ __ ] three weeks hey what happened to
you I hurt myself this is horrible and
I'm 45 years old in July as I try to
take a jacket up I hurt myself typing
because I had a deadline and I wanted my
wife to Purusha I had to get something
out at 4:30 p.m. and had to go out and I
promised it and I had to get my car and
drive somewhere cuz I cram way too much
[ __ ] in and I'm hunched over like the
animal typing and I get this draft out
and got up felt it go and I have and
that was maybe three and a half weeks
ago I haven't been the same since have
you stretched at all physical therapy at
go to the gym a lot and I had to go to
physical therapy told me exactly what it
was it's from the front not the back
right and I've been working on it it's
not right what's that you're right or
else you're yeah yeah your mess tickles
my back to balance this out and it's not
really working it's a it's really bad
and then I when I get angry when I used
to go on the road you searched for dude
I do it when you talk to people you kind
of argue when a call I do that all the
time and then I was in San Diego this
weekend and I go into when I do stand up
by going to this hunch mode where I just
start yelling at everyone and then I had
this guy in the front San Diego is such
a kind of Bobby will talk about this
because Bobby's Bobby Lee is from San
Diego but I hate it so [ __ ] much
because it's so date rapey it really is
if the Gaslamp District in San Diego if
there was like an arena for date rape
that's where it would be and there's
four guys to one girl
you should patent that by the way before
someone says arena for date rape in a
race he has the Octagon yeah for MMA you
could have the arena rape has the date
rape gas lamp district and it's all
girls holding their shoes walking around
barefoot winners quitters [ __ ] she's
not smart enough to bring flats but she
just can't tough it out to the car
that's a quitter okay she's only gonna
be there for the good times it's a major
[ __ ] sign
it is ladies if you see a guy wipe his
nose like this that's the same thing
that's a dope it's gotta be a little
subtle go like that maybe he can put a
baby in you so they sell they do to send
a lot of comedy clubs they sell VIP
tickets and so they'll let them walk in
first like if they there could be a huge
line of people waiting in the rain and
these VIP [ __ ] and I understand this
is what happened they got out of a limo
and then they put an arm in front of the
rest of people waiting in line and these
guys came in and then they sat in the
front row
Yolo douches what's that yeah yeah and
they were the most white de la hoya see
that's the other thing with San Diego
it's super super like privileges Mitt
Romney country La Hoya and there's just
chock full of conservative [ __ ] and
so they in the front row is look like
Thurston Howell he looked like he was
president of the La Jolla homeowners
association and I start going into this
Trump cilantro bit that I'm doing and I
see them rolling their eyes and I know
something's up and then it ends with
this is how it ends I'm hunched over
yelling he got up like a WWE villain and
while the whole crowd booed him because
I think I hunched down and I was looking
at and I'm a goad you're just upset
because you're looking into the horizon
and you see your death I go a [ __ ]
dressed like Santa when you do stand up
just to take the [ __ ] edge on and I'd
have a little bag of toys let you I
don't want to interact with anybody I
don't want to interact but you know what
he said to me he goes he goes I buy you
I'm the type of guy who [ __ ] pays you
and I just went nuts
you know I Wow oh yeah you break the
bottle and I wish i
Syria I have fan Harvey initials on his
cheek what did you do how did you notice
that I said ended a great like key buck
and I let him say I said sir please say
that into the microphone and I put the
mic right in front of him and I let him
say I by guys like you and the crowd
just went insane like everyone booed him
he walked out going because he knew he
was right [ __ ] money at me I'd pour
[ __ ] in the water supply so and then I
look down to the right hand side and I
look and there's this guy that was with
them and I go dude you need new friends
who is that [ __ ] [ __ ] and the guy
goes that's my dad dude that's a [ __ ]
it's a movie line i buy guys like you
walked out and I like them I like this
guy
want to hang out with the pony who
button-down Tommy Bahama shirt yes I did
him on this thing we should have been
like at what point my god you know the
person's bought like what is their
[ __ ] tell you know when you just walk
up to somebody can you size him up as
this looks about 75 bucks I wouldn't
have to go into triple digits with this
piece of [ __ ] yeah it's got a brand new
blue blazer everyday some crying child
to put the [ __ ] pocket square and
therefore so that did not help the
posture at all because I really leaned
into that one and then other than that
things are good I haven't really prior
to that I have that's what it really is
it's not from typing it's just from me
decades of you snapping on people and
just getting into their face you know
what I mean I've been pretty good
I really have I'm really trying to
I've been doing a lot of gardening you
have like prison glasses like whenever
you watch those prison shows like those
are the kind of glasses that get it you
know they make the evil [ __ ] genius I
saw a guy one third man I'm raising
little birds so this guy beat his
cellmate to death no he beat the [ __ ]
out of him and the guy lost an eye and
they when they goes and he was telling
this story almost like ended like if
somebody else did it and they were going
yeah they was looking for the eye and
the reporter goes what happened the eye
and he goes we don't know like he wasn't
part of it we don't know we were looking
for it he close he just like blacked out
and he was so proud of himself he said
if I was going to be in prison I decided
that I had to become a warrior he was
just sitting there with his ear to ear
grin like he was talking about childhood
dream well that's what I think a lot of
football players who was Lawrence
Phillips who just got murdered in his
south you know him he was the X st.
Louis Rams running back he was a 49er
for a little bit he got arrested and he
was murdered in his jail cell I think
those guys in like an Anthony Gonzalez
who's like those guys go in and they
have to establish everybody wants to go
did he go to jail for he I mean I think
he hit kids in his car it was like a
murderer to kid what the kids were in
the car go with the car he hit him with
the car all right I don't put you in
there started off as good parenting I'm
pretty sure that's what it was and just
throw that out there he murdered he
murdered his cellmate and then he got
murdered
that's what happened to him but yeah you
have to I think I don't get how you do
that it's like you want to get parole
but you don't want to get raped so this
like that fine [ __ ] line well you got
to stick up for yourself but you're not
trying to add more time right yeah you
don't want to come off as a [ __ ] but
you want to be like a model citizen in
there it's very tricky it's very tricky
yeah good behavior and not getting raped
time off for good behaviour just like
yeah you got [ __ ] in there didn't you
I just made a choice so it's just like I
now we haven't done one of these in a
while you see your course listening to
the all things comedy live podcast if
you don't know what all things comedy is
we decided actually in this parking lot
to start network and have all of our
friends do podcast we started with ten
podcast
Ari Shaffir Eddie Pepitone it was your
mom's house to start and then we grew
that and now I think it's 55 podcasts a
couple of our great friends are here
there's some amazing shows it's building
is turned into this actual business that
started again with two guys yelling in
the parking lot here and so now we're
doing this but would even up to how it
thinks it's been good you know I've my
anger has just been completely I had it
under control and I've just been
snapping my wife or I came home right
worked all day I was [ __ ] exhausted so
I called like my wife Ward is [ __ ] I
wanted this spaghetti and meatballs I'm
still so upset I can't even get it out
right they make the homemade pasta
that's all I'm thinking about is am in a
writers room so I'm just you know you
[ __ ] zone out I'm like I'm gonna get
spaghetti and meatballs so I come home
she calls up she ordered some fish
[ __ ] thing so I Drive up I show up
him I'm gonna get this thing pick it up
and I'll come buy it I said can you
postmates it in the restaurant well we
don't [ __ ] do that so I'm like [ __ ]
I'm gonna get in the car and I Drive
over to get it and I show up and I go
yeah hey you know order for bill and
they're like oh yeah we don't have the
fish so like we didn't put it in did you
still want the spaghetti and I just
[ __ ] was like I just turned around I
just walked out and I just was going
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] kind
of a [ __ ] spaghetti in a [ __ ] like
I literally had Tourette's I heard
people laughing who are eating on the
sidewalk and then the best part I look
like a complete maniac with my Aryan
haircut [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
I get my Prius and
drive away all the time I get it tonight
I went to back out you know it [ __ ]
drives me nuts in this city
pedestrians there's zero pedestrians
until you want to make a left and then
it's like The Truman Show and there's
that douche walking on his phone right
so I'm literally backing out of my
driveway and there's this woman walking
with like a boyfriend or something and I
mean I waved him on as I was in my car
with the windows up go yeah there you go
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
go ahead yeah take a good time yeah yeah
I'm sure you're underpaid right you
[ __ ] [ __ ] right and then I just
stopped and I was like bill
she's a pedestrian she had the right of
way there was a man there you never
addressed it the [ __ ] is I gradually I
talked myself dumb but when the windows
are up dude the [ __ ] that comes out of
my mouth horrible oh it's horrible it's
horrible yeah I wish death upon those
eye cars you know where they have like
the cameras it doesn't [ __ ] Steve
Jobs have a car that he didn't invent
after he died that he's taking credit
for beyond the grave you know doesn't he
don't they have one of those and they
own the rights to your registration and
everything like it god help us whenever
that happens oh where they can see you
yeah like [ __ ] oh yeah your TV they can
just turn you know when you were in your
hotel room they can just [ __ ] if
there's a speakerphone they can just
listen to you if they want so if you up
that rubber why not hang down oh yeah
everybody you're not covering your
camera on your computer you're crazy
your laptop and your camera it's over I
don't care what sort of vision you have
what something for view lack you got to
do that you definitely got to cover your
camera also my click not Hitler jerking
off all of that [ __ ] it never would have
happened
sitting there with that thing flapping
and that weird mustache speaking it do
you think he jerked off to probably like
epic fails it up
just love seeing people in pain I had I
got I was working these last couple days
in Chatsworth I were to chat with today
and Chatsworth is done in Chatsworth
California everybody knows is known for
porno that's where all the porno was
made I didn't know and that's where they
cuz they had to go outside and I ain't
got all this explanation they had to go
outside Los Angeles and then they passed
a condom law and so then I guess we lost
all that business but in Chatsworth
that's where all the porter was so I had
this driver who said he was local and I
was asking I go so all the porno was out
here huh and he goes yeah the porno was
out here and he goes actually he goes I
was I was watching some point they're
not supposed to say stuff like this and
the next part is not professionally
because I was watching some porno and I
was watching was one of those pornos
where you know the girl is a little
girls on the swing yeah that's where I
got and I go to I go I go no I don't
know those types of pornos and he goes
you know and like a pervert is looking
at the girl and then they panned around
and there was my house and yeah that
[ __ ] happened and we were like the
other thing is like we just started we
were I was 45 minutes away from home so
I had a sit in the car with that guy for
45 minutes but that's not a convert
that's not that's not professional let's
we good at a window in the window
so let's start with the circle chilling
out I guess now this is when I came over
here this other microphone wasn't
working are we good on it now do you
take Karen it's uh alright ladies and
gentlemen first coming to the shows you
ready to go coming on is a good friend
of mine I've known him for I've known
you for a long [ __ ] time huh yeah
probably
and I was like 20 I've the best picture
by the way of you and bill bill
reluctantly hugging you maybe seven
years ago all right ladies and gentlemen
big round of applause he's got a new
podcast on a TC called tiger belly right
big round of applause for Bobbie Lee Lee
oh there it is there I am how's it going
that I'm good Billy nice nice Bobby
thanks for having me on the on the show
and her and your all things comedy thing
your girlfriend was in the hospital she
had her titties out how big were these
boobs they're big they're like this and
then we took them out so would she go
did she get she get fixed up though
right do you don't they're out I know
that you take the boobs out so she had
big boobs now she had fake titties she
had fake titties but now she has a
little kiwifruit ones that I like I
don't like them big I like I'm like a
little tiny fruits that's always so
weird to me that you would go like from
little tude like that big yeah that
would be like I got a toupee you know I
have it [ __ ] make you act like
nothing happened I would never do that
to you that's [ __ ] ridiculous well
when I met her she had small ones that
she already had the appointment to do it
and I told her not to do it but she got
him done and then she had all these like
health issues after she got them done so
she got a man what would you give in a
[ __ ] gun what I say yeah [ __ ] said it
no but I wanted to because they don't
start a fight and stop you know man so I
just let it go you know but they were
like leaking or anything
there was like black ooze inside yeah
yeah as a coating blood inside I'm sorry
credible right yeah after that if you
took it like a [ __ ] sandwich bag of
chemicals stuck it in your body
thank you would have thought that you
know that would be a problem that's
unbelievable
and then how's the show going you know
you guys are friends with tree of boobs
but you guys like have a lot of porn
who's that Asian we have also curiosity
on the show and I met AUSA Kira when she
wasn't a porn star she was 17 what yeah
I was in New York about 15 years you see
yeah house this limo driver road again
how'd you meet her when she was 70 well
I was working at the Laugh Factory in
New York and I sold no tickets so Jamie
Masada goes buddy at the you know hand
out flyers oh and he hired this little
Japanese girl she was in high school and
we exchanged emails we had a great day I
didn't [ __ ] her or anything I'm you know
I'm an I'm a Christian and stuff and uh
and over the years on Facebook she'd be
like I'm a dominatrix now and then three
years later I'm the number one
dominatrix and then like five years
after that I went to the porn store on
Western cuz I like to jerk off and stuff
and uh I got this asian porn which I
normally don't do you know man I like
why you keep it real that's cool Asian
chicks because like in the darkness when
your eyes get adjusted to their face
they look like cousins and uncles and
stuff you're a man I mean that's truly
in the movie one so I try not to do that
and the one time I dated this power
ranger beautiful she was a Power Ranger
the yellow one and I don't know why they
made the Asian the yellow one but she
didn't need a suit actually uh and one
night at like 3:00 in the morning I woke
up and she was hovering over my body
her hair was across her face and she was
just staring at me and I broke up with
her the next day
that's the ring [ __ ] I don't like the
ring yeah yeah no you can't have it
that's you can have a transcends race
now I was I was talking about San Diego
a secret model standing over you like
that yeah yeah she's probably thinking
what if I just killed him
I know yeah what was she doing just like
me what she was also one of those I'm
gonna name her name her name but she
also dates just like Korean dudes that
have kind of a celebrity so later you
found out that she did it you know me I
don't want to name him other Koreans
[ __ ] I'm gonna name names Gangnam style
guy no like David Choe the artist he
dated she hated the Asian dude from link
limp Biskit there was an Asian guy in
limbus right right oh right yeah yeah
thank God
yeah what about the Gangnam style guy he
lives in Korea yeah so she didn't get to
him but she got the second best thing me
and then and then I just broke up with
her I miss her but you know I have a new
girlfriend it's fine let's move on hey I
was talking about San Diego you're from
San Diego has always been that many guys
it seems like such a [ __ ] horrible
place I hate it so much
oh you go in the water all the water's
polluted they're super-conservative but
they're on the border and so they hate
Mexicans but they're right there on the
front line yeah yeah yeah right well I
never got live in San Diego that's cuz
there's so many [ __ ] guys it's called
Maine Diego
because it's a military city and also um
it's just kinda sweet weirdly
conservative and I was always fat
minority and I just couldn't get laid
but as soon as I went to LA I got some
so I know this is a conservative state
excuse me this is a conservative state
where la is oddly liberal right place
else the [ __ ] Burbank through there
like psycho psycho like Arizona
conservative yeah yeah I saw that I just
was looking at this map of hate groups
for some reason and 57 hate groups in
California Prince Harry's brutal brutal
yeah oh I just wanted you get Hitler's
day off in Orange County a lot of people
don't know that my high school reunion
that was for Southern California went to
high school in San Francisco but they
had a little like everybody in Southern
California got together and we did that
last Friday and I'm sitting next to this
guy from my class and everyone's going
around telling what they do and then he
says he stands out I have two kids I'm a
li a delegator at the disk firm and then
he goes I'm the senior fundraising guy
in Orange County for Ted Cruz and then
you stand up like I got before he is
asked and hit the seat I sit up and go
but don't hold that against him he's a
good guy
and got a big laugh and now can I please
move can someone please switch seats
that there are like that's what la is
Orange County is super and La Jolla is
saying one of the widest places of all
yeah that's where I start what's wrong
well I mean your wife know your but your
yeah your life so you know trying to
bring it back you know trying to bring
white guys back just unbelievable know
we're all evil every one of us none of
us are cool now there's there's a small
group of cool white white guys no
[ __ ] areas the white guy
you can't say that about any other group
it's a bunch of Jews what else is going
on are you on you're on the road I'm on
the road Allah and then I'm doing a
little reoccurring thing on love which
is on Netflix and stuff and then that's
pretty much it yeah yeah I probably work
much since MADtv they're fine and but
I've been doing the road and it's been
really good you know now what's it like
doing a podcast also with your
girlfriend's I I try to keep everything
completely separate I have no I mean
it's like move yeah I mean it's
stressful but the thing is is that she's
good at what she does you know I mean so
I wouldn't have done it if she wasn't
she couldn't do it but she knows how to
do it and and it's fun you know it's
fine we fight a lot but we talk about my
sexual problem lot going on right yeah
what I use a lot going on yeah people
don't know that but I do have that you
do what yes yeah I can't watch porn
anymore because I can't get hard for on
anybody if I because I watched so much
porn what's so funny about that
that's on the cop that's on that that's
on the cover of Time magazine
what cover Time magazine kids who never
got laid ever in her life I've watched
so much [ __ ] porn yeah the body does
not respond when it's another [ __ ]
human being desensitize thank you sir
yes god damn it that's great he [ __ ]
I just talking for like three paragraphs
he just goes be sensitive [ __ ]
environmentalist with words
so anyway I quit watching porn wow
that's a huge sin because you had a
tremendous library I had how many days
you gone well only two days right now
because she just had surgery and so like
she's laying in bed and then um I go to
reality kings and then you know I'll
watch and then I'll do it you're a man I
pay for my porn because I like it hi-def
like I can't watch a blurry I need to
see freckles and fallopian tubes and all
that stuff you know man yeah that's yeah
now we got to go down the rabbit hole
alright so the last thing you jerked off
to what the laughs when you finally were
just like you know what I gotta stop
there is a girl on a swing I have a
particular thing that I and I know need
therapy over it but I need um there did
it be an interview beforehand
right so it's gotta get to know him your
and they have to be new to the business
so they have to go this is my first time
or whatever right and then when she's
having sex I have to see in her eyes
that she made a bad decision mommy
German yeah so I have problems I told
you that already
I'm sorry I stopped nine days ago did
you really I just sound done you're done
I'm done yeah it's just it's just yeah
it's sad I can't remember what the last
one was I just remember where I was I
was in Ottawa Ottawa Canada in this
state capital to filing myself and I
just was finally like I can't do this
anymore
well is it your arm your girlfriend is
african-american is it your wife I mean
my bad
yes my bad teach you not to be too
african-american porn I'm really user
friendly dude I found your comments
about Asian women way off
yeah I kind of like them all oh cool
why wouldn't you I know right yeah you
don't do it right no no never about
having kids you become such a [ __ ]
liar
yeah you know I don't do it I don't
that's the difficulty I have with
everything because you're so right when
you're all hunched over dude on your
show I well even with my kids in
homework right now my daughter I was the
worst possible student that you could
imagine and so now I have kids and I
don't want them to make the same
mistakes but in terms of math like how
is it possible for me to say you need to
do this do your math homework like this
is important because it's not important
is that we live in a really [ __ ] nice
house I why why math I I can't do it at
all is it would it be bad as a parent to
look at your kid and just be like hey
you know I sucked at this too I'd said
it I've said that I said I'm horrible at
look at me you're gonna I'm doing fine
and things are great and you add
subtract you can all need to multiply a
little bit you mind
dividing rarely comes up dividing
doesn't come up comes up in your 20s
when before you're gonna rent the same
[ __ ] place sure it's just like unless
you think building a [ __ ] with the
triangles and stuff it's just found
wrong just force-feeding that down like
musicians throats and other I don't know
whatever other job there is well in LA
there's there's a lot man give me the
[ __ ] word to helping patients you
were you good student you were you into
horrible I should have gone to summer
school all four years of high school I
went my sophomore year my freshman year
sophomore year she hooked me up with a
d-minus we had we didn't have EPS we had
ease she cooked me up with that then
11th grade I had to go to summer school
then 12th grade I should have gone
summer school but at that point I was
like what what is the point mhm it's
over I'm not in any good schools but you
went to a good college you went to
Emerson didn't you I worked my way back
into Emerson like I had to go to I went
to a bunch of colleges and then I
finished up there and like the math
requirement at Emerson was like adding
fractions and even then people were like
complaining like yeah I'm soaring out
we're gonna we're gonna sit up here and
talk the entire time let's bring out our
next guest ladies Jay he's got a new
podcast with atc called poundcake one of
my very good friends big round flaws for
Rory Scovel ladies and gentlemen I hope
this one works a switch and this this is
not this is on yeah it's great
I'm good how are you guys going I I
don't have any perverted porn stories I
have a daughter now and I golf a lot so
this should be a pretty adventurous
conversation yeah guys try to get to two
degenerates and a couple of married guys
up here yeah guys with the glasses
somehow not watching a lot of porn I
don't know that computer screen 9 what's
the longest you've ever gone not
watching porn if you're at nine days now
is that currently the record well I
never kept stats so I would say yeah a
couple of weeks I'm [ __ ] bored you
just do I don't I don't think there's
any way out I think once you're in
you're in for life I think once you buy
a laptop you're like hi I would like a
laptop so I can jerk off the rest of my
life with this device this is like an
anti intervention just scratch the itch
just [ __ ] there's so much porn you
can't see it all you getting out too
soon yeah I once you have kids and
they're in the other room there's no you
can't do that in the house like I feel
weird about that like you have kids in
the house so that just is out the window
so have you tried that no I know you
can't with the word alright but shut the
[ __ ] up what is it what's the magic
what's right really do went to when I
came home and for the 30 minutes that I
was home my kids were really upset they
were trying to crack open a coconut it
was [ __ ] hilarious I got it we all
picture our family to be doing he was
trying to crack open a coconut I don't
feed him anymore anyway so I got a drill
and I I would drilled a couple holes in
we threw some straws in it but I can it
was it's adorable those are priced of
children that he doesn't feed Charlie
Charlie Hill is an old comedian from
here that we knew when we first started
and he grabbed me early on right my
daughter was born and said 7 8 9 year
old daughter is gonna be your best
friend and it really is true so now my
daughter is 10 years old and it's
fantastic it really she plays piano and
I really love my kids are hilariously I
love your kids too great great kids I
met them yes I like them yeah Bobby came
over for dinner and didn't know one time
he got up a huge camp said we were gonna
he kept getting up and running going to
the other end of a pole and trying to
get this stuff on the other end of the
table I'm like no we're gonna pass it to
you man I'd never get invited to
weddings or like people's houses so that
was like once-in-a-lifetime thing so I
didn't know how the thing worked in
freak sout if he's not in a comedy club
he [ __ ] free I years ago we had the
apartment you came over you brought
those nice bowls of cereal and no matter
what we did he could not get comfortable
yeah yeah he gave us all these gifts
kind of just you know shifty in this
little one-bedroom you [ __ ] sit down
and if for some reason I got you old boy
the Korean movie I'm like here here's a
[ __ ] up movie ever made but one of the
great fight scenes of all that tracking
oh my god if you haven't seen the Korean
version that that hallway scene is the
best if I Cleary make that yeah did he
did he make it
yay did I didn't see it yeah I'm Josh
Brolin played the guy I love Josh I do
too he's very likeable but I refused I
refuse to watch that I also refuse to
watch black Annie
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you know you know what
I'm saying you shouldn't remake classics
now because well because she's black
because they already got it perfect
yeah - perfect note to self stop writing
Mexican Annie
and then what else is going on with you
- you had Rory has a brand-new baby wait
you hate the whiz kid that happens to be
a black one - didn't like it
you don't like black remakes no I just
don't you know they made a black Steel
Magnolias that's when it was too far
from today fair it's the payback for
Elvis he stole all that [ __ ] music
and they come back and they stay calm
everybody is even it's a circle -
perfect Christmas black and black steel
magnet is black before the title like
everything I thought they'd get a bigger
laugh anyways nothing not much is going
on with me it's all baby for anyone
you're thinking about having kids it is
you it's great but it is the end so it's
I think I liken it to what I assume
heroine is you're probably this is the
greatest what's over it's probably over
once you've gone down that path and you
love it but you know that before you had
a kid I had an idea I had an idea that
that's probably what I was walking into
was it was a guy that once we have this
kid but then I was also like well maybe
I can kind of convince my wife like I
don't know what I'm doing I shouldn't be
here well what am I gonna add I don't
know let me get out of here where you
going tomorrow you're going to Tribeca
right Tribeca Film Festival he's in a
movie that's gonna be premiering at the
Tribeca Film Festival and comedy and
acting is the perfect balance for having
a family because we get to [ __ ] leave
and if I had a nine-to-five it's great
for a relationship because anybody who
went you know if you go and do your
normal thing and you go 9:00 to 6:00
every single day and you go you
it's [ __ ] horrible I would kill
myself but we get to leave and it's
amazing and it really do absence makes
the heart grow fonder and you end up
missing everybody they miss you and it's
fantastic reset you hit the reset I'll
just go sit in a parking lot for a few
hours just get out of the house I gotta
go I gotta work on my craft I have to go
right and I'll just sit in a parking lot
check Twitter nowadays that's supportive
right I gotta go right I mean tweet for
a couple hours stay relevant let's bring
out our next comic I'm not sure how
we're gonna do this he also he is uh
next to bill on the network he I think
he has our most popular podcast it's
called the dollop oh yeah how about this
I have to go to the bathroom so I'll and
then and then you know come back all
right that's great ladies gentlemen from
the dollop he also has point versus
point he has two podcasts on the network
Gareth Reynolds says Angela
and then come back Wahby now I didn't
realize that I was looking at the
numbers you guys heard dial-up is
[ __ ] hugely popular yeah why don't
you explain to everybody what it is and
explain to the other group the dollop is
an American history podcast where every
week I get a story that's insane from
American history that I don't know about
explain to me and I just react to it so
Dave Anthony and this stuff is insane
so that Rory Rory you both did one and
Yuri I've Rory hadn't listened to it
before he did it and he was like what
the [ __ ] is this it was like dave was
writing these fantasy stories but it's
actual stuff but it's now I was about
the one I was on was about a religion it
was called the Lorenz II what is it I
don't remember it's like a Wisconsin
Christianity sect then they're down to
the last two people yeah ever in it but
it was hugely popular at one time it's
ridiculous so when was the heyday of it
it was like like recently like the 80s
like 70s and 80s oh do people abandon it
or they all died people okay I think a
combo yeah I think I'll died out but
there's two left so it's like you know
it's like dodgeball when there's you
know there's two maybe someone catches
it who knows what's gonna happen and
what else did like in terms of like if
you wanted to point anybody to any
particular episode there's a great one
about the rube waddell who was a pitcher
who in his offseason would do stuff like
wrestle alligators and people would hold
up puppies to distract him during a game
and it would work he would fight fans
like he'd go into the crowd like he'd
walk through the crowd and just start
fighting people drunk on the way there
like important memorabilia balls he
would just be like you know what team
and what do you remember I don't
remember what team he played for I don't
when he was I mean he was around siyoung
he was actually a better picture than
siyoung technically but nobody knows
about him because he was just out of his
[ __ ] tents
he was just insane and then there's
other good ones about like a lobotomy
started which is like a fun ride
speaking of rides the guy who started it
actually did have a lobotomy Biel
where he would drive from city to city
giving lobotomies on stage in front of
fans no way I swear to God
to who it was like people it was like
The Beatles people like oh my god to the
bottom you guys here and then he bring
him up and he like pound like an ice
pick into people like four at a time and
people be like it was like it was like
Ritalin I swear to god it was like
ritalin they'd be like my daughter's not
focused he'd be like well let me just
hit that frontal lobe and she'll either
be for like 25% of people would just be
like what happened everybody remember
this story the next time you hear the
national anthem wait and then what
happened the other ones would just yeah
like 25% nothing would happen they be
like I feel great and then the other 24
75% of be like huh just left town and
they realized that he broke them I think
eventually enough cities were like this
actually is terrible and then he was out
of business Kennedys do that yeah they
lobotomize like a 12 year old yeah yeah
kid they had a kid and I guess it was
gonna be a Republican I can't remember
how was you know what you need to get
your mind right yeah and they tried it
it was a bad no she had the electric
shock thing or she got a little boner I
think she got a lobotomy too I think she
got both luckily she got two of them
that's it fine and she just was like not
in anymore family photos now but she
voted liberal she did vote with the
party lines from then on thankfully it
was easy to make her vote though you
just be like blue yeah Joe Kennedy and
then you had a you have another one
going called point versus point right
which is a weekly debate show that
doesn't actually get to the topic it's
more about the host pickering hilarious
I wanted to do that I had an idea for a
show called you know how the Chris
Hardwick does all those talking shows
like afterwards say so it's talking dead
and then I think he does what it was for
him for he had one for like breaking bad
talking
yeah and then I sort of what I want to
do what I want to do I want to do
talking castle Fez show castle will
never get no one knows what [ __ ]
castles about so what do you guys think
it was tonight yeah guys think was about
tonight so I just have to explain castle
to the person and then we have to talk
about whatever no I don't never seen it
TV shows it's been on the air for it's
been on the air for nine years it's
scripted yeah it's a procedural show
sometimes it feels like it's a I know
what it's about it's about a he's a
writer and then they brought him in to
help solve crimes and that's the show
Murder She Wrote yes
but with a guy they did Murder She Wrote
Murder She Wrote castles yeah
and then you were on a you got to do a
TV show you're on a pilot yeah I was in
Atlanta for a couple weeks
shooting a pilot for ABC did you go to
did you masturbate in the hotel room
no actually funny you should ask out
downstairs where the free Wi-Fi was yeah
just sit there loaded in the lobby sorry
I I don't watch I don't need that much
porno
you don't watch a lot of porn no got
waffle surprising wait while the guy's
making waffles
it's just jerk yeah now I'm saying no
one got the waffles the next day oh yeah
second they saw the batter they were
like oh that reminds me of jizz to
explain the hole do you ever bring me on
the road do you ever bring her on out on
the road to like any I would like to but
she only goes to the fun cities that's
when she supports me she's
oh you're going to New York I'm gonna be
there for you when I'm going to Dayton
I got Moines Iowa coming up pretty
healthy I don't know how about Jordan
does Jordan ever go on there no she
doesn't
I think I'd enjoy it but I mean I don't
do anything I'm not like a person who's
like I leave my wife at home and I [ __ ]
whenever I can
I'm not a jerk-off in the why do you
call yourself road Rory when you're gone
your eyes like Road Rory's back so I
think it's a cool nickname okay I drove
to be here look out watch out
I drove yeah I don't do anything even
like as soon as the show's over I just
go to bed I don't even know that it's
literally the smartest thing you could
do it's that feels great
yes it does he I said if the show was at
6:00 I would go to bed at like 8:00 if
that was fine if it was possibly get in
bed sooner I would I still go out I
still party man yeah I go to like the
all the waitstaff says we're gonna go
somewhere I'll [ __ ] said all right
I'll see you there and you know what you
don't know
how goes back to the hotel and changes
puts in a leather suit puts on his
delirious suit yeah when I was in New
York over the summer I was trying to
practice herself that I brought my wife
and kids to we were I think it was like
Rochester New York it was we're gonna
take everybody to Niagara Falls and then
we took him to it was like this was the
begging it was it was a place called the
comedy club but it was a attached to a
country-western bar bar called daisy
dukes and then I went in check bounced
what we would nicest hotel was a Holiday
Inn and Suites hmm and then my
six-year-old daughter at the time we get
into the hotel room she opens up the
curtain the blinds and she says why am I
looking at the parking lot whoa
and I go because we're on the road baby
the worst possible gig and I said we're
gonna go battle businessmen for pancakes
and waffles tomorrow morning
everybody look alive like a bottom floor
next to a nice machine and I said and
then I looked at everyone I go this is
what it's like this is what I do when
you guys are home staying home do you
know in the comfort to our home I'm out
killing myself [ __ ] with Sam in the
park
all those years yelling at your kids
Jesus out and I bet they didn't they
were looking at you like what the [ __ ]
dude we came out here just to support
you why are you yelling at it's good
lesson I can't have them think that is
all this is easy and they forget do they
forget cuz then a lot of times I brought
my wife out and then she comes when she
comes back and it's totally [ __ ]
exhausted she's just like you know I
don't know how you do this I don't know
how you do this I couldn't do this I was
like yeah it's [ __ ] brutal this shows
a fun but all of the travel and all that
[ __ ] is brutal the food and all that
crap and then like like it maybe won the
next gig she remembers and then the next
year you come back and they the second
you get in the house we got all this
stuff to [ __ ] I just stare at the
[ __ ] wall for the next three days and
not do anything it's rough uh what else
I do you know you're on day nine huh
yeah I came home with the Time magazine
that was saying how [ __ ] pornos bad
it's like look at this [ __ ] I had an
idea that this was a bad thing so uh
Time magazine you know it's not like
it's [ __ ] people right they sort of
research it I wonder have now every time
you come home so Mike did you jerk off
like it's her first question is it still
going or did you jerk I would tell she
doesn't give a [ __ ] did you tell her to
look alive it's game on she better be
ready to go so she actually kind of said
something like that I was like yes so
I'm kind of done with porn so you need
to be
yeah
get ready yeah that's basically it so
I'm wonderful she's so [ __ ] over me
she's probably gonna tell me maybe a
little bit of porn is just getting a
little needy you know we just go for a
walk
and what's your I don't know your
relationship status what's your I don't
see you're not married I'm not I'm
single said I have a kick thank you one
lady keep it up yeah thank you
yeah you're never gonna fully
appreciates like being young you can't
appreciate it - you're an old [ __ ] it
being singles the same thing yeah well I
also I'm getting locked into something
even though you love them and everything
you'd be like what the [ __ ] was I
thinking yeah yeah I should have been
call girls in cocaine you know just I
think you crazy [ __ ] yeah no I don't
know I just like I feel like when I
watched my parents they were like they
got my parents got married at like 19
and then I just watched like
deterioration for like 20 I just watched
them slowly like you know like little
little jabs turned into like arguments
turned into like they would go like a
mile away from my house and I could
watch them just like mimes shout at each
other and I was like I don't like that
that I know yeah so I just now just you
know someone comes along great but I
have a cat like I said some things are
good and then also you're on you you're
on television you know this is uh this
is exciting when I married my wife it
was way Priebe doing stand-up comedy and
now I mean look there's a lot do you
worry though that somebody's not gonna
marry you for you or you're okay with
that yeah
if she could pretend forever I'm okay
with that like if she can wake me out
then god bless her way to go yeah as
long as she as long as she's really
committed you know then I'm into it this
place got really loud what's that it's
the same lady from before is here with a
gentleman who right now is like quit
trying to [ __ ] that guy is Bobby gonna
come back Oh perfect that is true yeah
what are you talking about come a little
bit wait for it at the end of the
[ __ ] show we're not musicians we sing
twinkle twinkle little stars and 12
[ __ ] come up to you it up here it's
kind of fun to pretend a white guy who
just came out of the audience knows one
time I was in Chicago I was doing the
Schomburg improv and I got backstage and
there was a fat white lady completely
naked with her legs spread open no it
never happened if I look at like here
how was the manager manager he was
saying good show
but what I'm saying is is that I'm
pretty much unfuckable and but the
reason why daddy does kills it is
because of that and there you go and I'm
a machine and that's nothing you can do
about it perfect place for a service
version of my jack see the exact same
jacket sleeveless feature act version we
are we are not really set up to make
that much money but if you go to the
website all things comedy dot-com you
see actually there's a great t-shirt in
the back that you can buy that yeah it
is a good shirt writing comfortable I
didn't have to have some borderline 13
year old [ __ ] wearing it like that
[ __ ] whatever that guy's name is
who's the guy with the t-shirts the soft
t-shirts you know you drive down the
street you go look at the ass on that
all [ __ ] she's eight
who is that the American Apparel
American Apparel yeah gets creeped out
by those [ __ ] now yeah against pubic
hair poundcake that was going to be a
shorter thing but he's continuing to do
it and then also to podcasts the dollop
which you hopefully are intrigued you
want to listen to a lot of amazing
information and then one of the funniest
wittiest guys have ever been around
Gareth and Dave Anthony big round of
applause for everybody
all things comedy one more time for Bill
Byrne Tommy Lee
Rory Scovel Garrett Reynolds Bobby light
al Madrigal thank you very much
everybody good night take care thank you
thank you